sieht das gehört haben das Wort mit den
Paschas den Satz mit den Paschas was
haben Sie gedacht
mittlerweile als Mann von der Basis
gelernt ich werde das p-wort nicht in
den Mund nehmen weil ich habe erkannt
welches verhetzungspotential dieses Wort
hat aber ich stelle mir die Frage
debattieren wir wirklich darüber was
gemeint ist dann denn wenn ich mir
anschaue unter der Prämisse das
Migration auch in meinem Landkreis im
Großen und Ganzen eine Erfolgsgeschichte
ist aber wenn ich in meine Kindergärten
schaue in die Schulen in die normale
Interaktion dann dann haben wir ein
Problem damit dass wir Verhaltensweisen
haben die finde ich mit dem Keyboard
eigentlich noch verniedlichen
umschrieben die die Frau nicht ernst
nehmen muss konkret zu machen dass
LehrerInnen nicht ernst genommen werden
von Vätern das Mütter nicht alleine zu
elternsprechtabenden kommen dürfen
das junge Frauen Mädchen in der
Berufsschule Angst davor haben wenn sie
sich im Unterricht äußern dass Jungs
Männer in der Verwandtschaft das
weitererzählen weil sie unter der
Kontrolle stehen der der männlichen
Familienmitglieder warum was ist schlimm
daran sich im Unterricht zu äußern ja
weil es kann ja sein dass das dass sie
dort Dinge äußert die auch in die ich in
der liberalen Gesellschaft freiheitlich
Beispiel konkreten ein wichtiger
interessieren was ihnen konkret durch
den Kopf geht wenn Sie das sagen ja wir
hatten vor einigen Monaten in unserer
Berufsschule einen Projekt wo es Umgang
mit Judentum mit jüdischen Menschen
gehen und dann geht's darum dass das
gewisse Männer meinen wenn ich Muslimin
bin darf ich mit jüdischen Menschen
nicht reden und das Problem ist würde
sie jetzt im Unterricht mit dieser
Person sprechen dann wird es aber
durchgesteckt kommt in der Familie und
dort hat es dann für sie negativ
und und ich denke über über diese Formen
müssen wir schon sprechen das ist nicht
ich möchte noch mal sagen ja ist auch
gerade mein Landkreis wir sind
industrielandkreis wir haben wir haben
eine starke Migrationsgeschichte und die
Migration ist den großen Teilen gelungen
aber wenn Sie auch in Zukunft gelingen
soll und wenn Integration gelingen soll
dann müssen wir auch den Mut haben
Missstände ganz offen anzusprechen ohne
dass wir dann diffamiert werden dass wir
damit alle verunglimpfen wollen aber wir
müssen über die Missstände sprechen
können um auch was dagegen unternehmen
zu können
na sie sind nicht in der CSU auch nicht
in der CDU sind auch nicht in der SPD
sind ein grüner Landrat ja
also das jetzt so sagen sie überlegen
Sie sich ja ganz genau in so einer
Sendung auch wie kommt das draußen in
ihrer grünen Blase an ihre eigene Partei
der Ausgangspunkt meiner Arbeit ist
jetzt nicht die grüne Blase ist nicht
die Grüne Partei ich habe als Landrat
eine Verantwortung für mein Landkreis
und da fängt die Politik mit der
wahrnehmigung der Wirklichkeit an ja und
wenn ich natürlich jetzt darüber darüber
spreche dass nicht alles beim Thema
Integration Migration gut läuft sorgt es
natürlich erstmal für eine gewisse
Aufmerksamkeit in der grünen Partei das
ist es natürlich kein kein kein kein
wunderschönes
Thema aber es wird zugehört und und ich
glaube es gehört auch dazu dass das
Themen die einem sehr am Herzen liegen
der im sehr wichtig sind dass man dann
auch gerade da über über Fehlentwicklung
und wenn sie nur Teilen sind die offen
anspricht
anstrengender das funktioniert ist
anstrengend genau das ist ja sehr wohl
auch gleich mit juli Zehner sprechen
wollen ich meine wenn man sowas sagt
meine Erfahrung ist immer jemand der
auch hier in der Sendung sitzt der
überlegt sich ganz genau möchte ich ein
ruhiges Wochenende haben oder habe ich
stehe ich das durch ja
sie wollen darüber habe ich nachgedacht
ja tue ich es mir an sehen Sie ich
wusste oder mache ich mir einen schönen
ruhigen Abend zu Hause und und der
Sprache ist so sie haben sich jetzt
angetan ja im Januar haben Sie schon
einen Brief geschrieben offenbar brennt
die Hütte der Art dass sie sagen muss
jetzt sein ja was was war der Anlass für
für diesen für diesen will ich sagen
Brand Brief ist es eigentlich genauso
gemeint es ist ein Hilferuf gewesen es
ist ein Hilferuf gewesen dass das sowohl
auf der Bundes- und landespolitischen
Ebene Problematik bitte wirklich
wahrgenommen wird und wir nicht diese
parteipolitischen Streitereien dieses
oberflächliche Gerede über Migration
Integration über Flüchtlinge sondern
wirklich wahrnehmen dass wir auf der
kommunalen Ebene weil wir haben am Ende
die Aufgabe die Menschen ja nicht nur
unterzubringen worüber vor der Gründe
gesprochen mit hauptsache sie haben
irgendwo in den Bett und wenn es
irgendwo noch in der Notunterkunft ist
sondern wir haben die ganzen Folge
Aufgaben der Betreuung der Integration
und und wir wir sind im Jahr 22 im
Herbst Winter in der Situation hinein wo
wir einfach sehenden Auges
unsere Leistungsgrenzen wirklich
nachhaltige überschreiten und nicht mehr
in der Lage sind das verantwortungsvoll
zu leisten
die Lage der Aufnahme und Versorgung der
geflüchteten ist prekär und droht für
uns Kommune nicht mehr beherrschbar zu
werden ja
über welche Zahlen reden wir ein
Landkreis ist ungefähr 130.000 Menschen
groß ja
und und sie haben helfen uns mal
man muss es ja mal ein bisschen
geschichtlich aufarbeiten wir hatten die
die erste große Phase in den Jahren 2014
folgende davon haben wir jetzt bestimmt
noch sieben 800 900 Menschen übrig die
die noch bei uns im Landkreis Leben und
mehr oder weniger noch betreut werden
wir haben im Vergangenheit mehr oder
weniger betreut werden lass uns bitte
einmal konkret reden hier ist sehr gerne
das heißt wenn wir jetzt in unsere
Berufsschule Miltenberg schauen habe ich
dort sieben berufsintegrationsklassen
das sind sieben Klassen mit mit jungen
Menschen so zwischen 18 und 25 und wir
bereiten die in zwei Jahren darauf vor
dass sie ausbildungsreif das sind das
ist eine berufliche Ausbildung beginnen
können und es sind
größtenteils Menschen die in den Jahren
14 15 16 zu uns gekommen sind sind wie
alt
so zwischen 18 und bis 25 okay ja und
daran arbeiten wir noch und es ist
richtig intensiver eine sensationell
engagierte Arbeit auch der der
Lehrkräfte
aber ja es geht jetzt noch darum die
fit zu machen für die berufliche
Ausbildung also wir sind da noch am
Arbeiten es ist noch nicht abgeschlossen
sein 25 junge Menschen in einer Klasse
25 ist im ersten Jahr die notwendigen
sprachlichen Fertigkeiten
gesellschaftliche Werteorientierung im
zweiten Jahr dann die berufliche
Vorbereitung ja trotzdem nochmal die er
meine Frage ist und deswegen habe ich
diesen also wenn man die nackten Zahlen
sieht dann versteht man diesen Aufschrei
nicht so richtig ja man hört die nackten
Zahlen man sagt 130.000 Leben bei ihnen
ungefähr Menschen genau und sie haben
ungefähr 3000
3000 und dann kommen jetzt noch mal wir
haben 1600 Menschen aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen dass das hat sehr gut
aufgrund der großen gesellschaftlichen
Einsatzbereitschaft Hilfsbereitschaft
sehr gut funktioniert und jetzt im
Herzen hat sich wieder in historische
höchstdimensionen die die Zuwanderung
geflüchtete aus Afghanistan aus Syrien
und aus dem nordafrikanischen Raum
entwickelt das bedeutet ich weiß das ist
glaube ich das größte Problem was wir
Kommunalpolitikerinnen landrät in den
Landräte haben dass die Zahlen nicht so
spektakulär werden ja was was heißt das
schon wenn in meinem Landkreis jede
Woche 30 40 geflüchtete kommen aber 30
oder 40 geflüchtete in der Woche heißt
ich brauche zwei neue dezentrale
Unterkünfte ich muss zwei Häuser
anmieten ich muss die finden wo finden
Sie die wir machen sie das mit
allmählich nicht mehr weil auch das was
was was gerade in den Großstädten nicht
wahrgenommen wird auch in den ländlichen
Räumen Landkreis Miltenberg
Metropolregion Frankfurt Rhein-Main wir
haben schon im vergangenen Jahrzehnt
Ende des Jahrzehnts hat sich in großer
Wohnraummangel entwickelt wenn wir
Fachkräfte anwerben wollen junge Leute
fehlt uns Wohnraum also wir haben schon
eine sehr gute Problematik sie können
die Leute schlicht nicht unterbringen
sie haben ich finde wir haben jetzt im
Januar noch mal ja gefühlt würde ich
sagen die letzten leerstehenden Häuser
akquiriert das wird jetzt immer schwerer
wir haben keinen Wohnraum und weshalb
ich ja auch immer darauf Hinweis es geht
nicht nur darum die Menschen jetzt in
Notunterkünften oder in
flüchtlingsunterkünften unterzubringen
die Menschen haben eine
Bleibeperspektive gerade wenn sie aus
Syrien aus Afghanistan kommen danach
müssen sie auf dem reg weiteren
Wohnungsmarkt
Wohnraum finden den haben wir de facto
nicht und dann kommt noch das Thema
Familiennachzug dazu und
ja das sind wir bei der Macht des
Faktischen wir haben diesen Wohnraum
nicht und ich sage nochmal da reden
jetzt alleine nur über den Wohnraum wenn
sie mich das jetzt gerade nur in
Kindergartenplätze wir haben momentan
Mühe unsere Bevölkerung überhaupt den
regulären Bedarf an Kindergartenplätzen
zu decken wir investieren die die
Gemeinden verschulden sich für den Bau
neuer Kindergärten unsere Schulen sind
voll
kinderärztliche Versorgung
nicht sie haben die Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer nicht die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
ja mittlerweile reichen abgeschlossenes
Studium und sie werden vor die Klasse
gestellt ja kinderärztliche Versorgung
wir hatten im vergangenen Sommer
Probleme gehabt bei den ukrainischen
Kindern die masernschutzimpfung die
Voraussetzung war um in den Kindergarten
zu gehen die war nicht über die
regulären medizinischen
Versorgungsstrukturen abdeckbar also es
ist viel
an allem
juli Zeh sagt mein Eindruck ist es sehr
interessant dass wir uns noch nicht an
dem Punkt befinden an dem wir das nicht
bewältigen können ja vielleicht das nun
frommerwunsch also ich glaube es gibt
Ballungszentren für diese Probleme das
sind gerade Regionen in den sowieso
schon Wohnungsnot herrscht wenig
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten bestehen aus
den Gegenden wo ich jetzt herkomme
Ostdeutschland eher ländlicher Raum ich
bin wirklich kein Experte ich will
nichts falsches sagen Ich höre es eher
so na durch Leute die in dem Bereich
arbeiten sind die Belastungsgrenzen noch
nicht erschöpfen da wäre eventuell noch
mehr Platz was mir auffällt ist dass die
Themen die Sie ansprechen Wohnungsnot
Bildungsnotstand ärztliche Versorgung
nicht gewährleistet Kindergartenplätze
fehlen das sind alles Bereiche in denen
wir auch schon jenseits von
flüchtlingsproblematiken als Land vor
Jahren angefangen haben zu versagen ja
also wo wir von falschen demografischen
Erwartungen ausgegangen sind wo wir
korrekte demografische Erwartungen
missachtet haben die Bedarf nicht
richtig eingeschätzt haben und einge
sofort eingeschwollt eingespart und
jetzt sind wir an einem Punkt wo jede
weitere Herausforderung eigentlich nicht
mehr zu stemmen ist ja also ich fände es
gut wenn man diese Themen noch ausweiten
würde und sagen das ist eine
Flüchtlingsproblematik aber das betrifft
auch unser gesamtes Land ja in seiner in
seinem substanziellen Aufbau das sind
eigentlich die tragenden Pfeile einer
Gesellschaft dass die Bildungs stimmt
das Wohnung da sind dass die
Gesundheitsversorgung da ist klassische
Daseinsvorsorge und wenn wir uns da den
spiegelfußgesicht halten und sagen da
sind wir an einem Rand angelangt ja da
können wir keinen Menschen mehr mit
integrieren aufnehmen dann ist das ein
Weckruf der weit über die von Ihnen
jetzt
adressiert
beschäftigt sich seit 20 Jahren mit
dieser Thematik wie kann es sein dass
wir immer wieder auf solche Situationen
zu steuern und alles wirkt unvorstellbar
hilflos bis hin zu dem EU
migrationsgipfel muss ich dieses
Abschlussdokument anguckt können wir
vielleicht auch gleich noch mal einen
Satz drüber reden ist dann so ganz
wattebauschig die Rede von Infrastruktur
die gebaut werden soll gemeint sind
Zäune aber keiner traut sich das Wort
Zeugen zu sagen also das unvorstellbar
viel Scheinheiligkeit und zumindest sich
nicht ehrlich machen im Spiel
wir sind manchmal ein bisschen wie die
drei Affen unterwegs so vor allem die
die sich die Augen also der Affe der
sich die Augen zuklappt das war 2015
auch nicht anders so der Krieg in Syrien
ist ja nicht 2015 ausgebrochen und die
Lage in den flüchtlingszentren vom UNHCR
von anderen ist ja nicht 2015 erst so
schlimm gewesen und dann das fing
sukzessive an wir haben immer gedacht
wir sind hier geschützt das erreicht uns
nicht und als durch Corona die Zahlen
runterging hat mir diese Illusion auch
wieder jetzt
regelt sich das pendelt sich das alles
wieder ein jetzt kommt nichts und hinzu
kommt allerdings zu Wahrheit gehört auch
der Ukraine Krieg stand bei vielen von
uns nicht auf dem Plan bei den
Amerikanern vielleicht viele haben lange
daran geglaubt das passiert nicht und
jetzt waren wir vor allem letztes Jahr
in der Situation in der der Libanon 2000
kollabiert 13 14 war oder die Türkei
weil wir als Direktor Nachbarstaat oder
als Nachbarstaat natürlich betroffen
waren zusammen mit Polen sind ja fast
identisch die Zahlen sind ja ungefähr
bei einer Million mit Polen aufgenommen
eine Million haben wir letztes Jahr
aufgenommen und ich bin ich bin komplett
bei bei meinen mitrednern die
Infrastruktur ist ja genau das Problem
es geht ja nicht darum dass wenn wir
sagen wir möchten Menschen aufnehmen
ihnen Schutz bieten ist ja alles richtig
aber wenn es nur die Aufnahme ist das
heißt ein darüber im Kopf und eine warme
Mahlzeit dann muss man sich tatsächlich
die Frage stellen ob man nicht eher in
den Herkunftsregionen hilft wo das
kriegen wir da nämlich auch hin es
gehört aber bei uns zu einer Integration
so wie wir es verstehen politisch
wahrhaben wollen dafür haben wir ja auch
lange gebraucht einfach mehr das fängt
beim Kitaplatz an es fängt bei den
Integrationskursen an das sind die
Schulen das sind ganz ganz viele andere
Faktoren das ist ein Wohnraum wie kann
denn Integration gelingen wenn ich
Menschen sehr sehr lange in
turnhallenhausen lasse es wird zwar 15 2
16 hatten 26 Turnhallen waren in meiner
Stadt in Köln
2015/16 belegt wie soll da Integration
gelingen also insofern all diese
Infrastruktur die dahinter steht die
haben wir nicht die haben wir schon ohne
Flüchtlinge nicht unbedingt Stichwort
auch Fachkräftemangel aber die haben wir
gerade bei einer so hohen Zahl die wir
aufnehmen wollen aufnehmen müssen
einfach nicht so dass wir am Ende sagen
eigentlich können wir diese Menschen gar
nicht in dieser Größe aufnehmen okay was
ist dann die Konsequenz daraus warum
sind wir nicht in der Lage auf politisch
das dann klar zu sagen
richtig verstehe völlig allein gelassen
hat ihn jemand geantwortet auf ihrem
Brief aus dem Bundeskanzleramt kam keine
Antwort allein gelassen fühle ich mich
nicht ich habe meine bayerischen
landratskolleginnen und Kollegen denn
die Geschichte meines Briefes hat ja die
Vorgeschichte dass wir uns im November
schon als bayerische Landrätin Landräte
gemeinsam an den Bundeskanzler gewandt
haben
auch keine Antwort bekommen haben das
habe ich dann meine eigenen nachgelegt
habe aber ich bekomme viel Zuspruch aus
der kommunalpolitischen Ebene auch aus
meiner Partei weil wir da schon jetzt
auch sehr intensiv konzeptionell darüber
diskutieren aber was ist denn die Lösung
Herrschaft das ist einmal nach vorne
diskutieren wie kann denn sowas aussehen
was bedeutet all das denn in der
Konsequenz
sehr viel das ist ja schon in der
Antwort gerade angeklungen ist es man
kann zum einen damit anfangen dass es
wirklich mit einer einer wirkungsvollen
Flüchtlingshilfe vor Ort in den Regionen
anfängt denn wenn wir uns dort die
Situation anschauen sehen wir dass die
Lage dort weitestgehend desolat ist das
heißt wir müssen da viel mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen die Vereinten
Nationen des flüchtlingshilfswerk äh
wieder
ermächtigen dort wirklich wirkungsvolle
Hilfe zu leisten und wir müssen uns dann
auch Gedanken darüber machen wenn wir
Menschen in Not helfen wollen nach der
Flüchtlingskonvention wie kommen die
Menschen zu uns denn jetzt ist es ja so
dass die Menschen nur die Möglichkeit
haben sei es aus Afghanistan
afrikanischen Raum über einen eigentlich
vollkommen desolaten Weg der von der von
Gewalt Kriminalität Schlepperei
Vergewaltigung und und allem geprägt ist
dann muss illegal die EU Außengrenze
dann muss man irgendwie noch
illegal durch die anderen EU-Länder zu
uns kommen um dann human geholfen zu
bekommen also
ich sehe schon den Bedarf dass wir uns
darüber wirklich konzeptionell Gedanken
machen müssen wie sieht das wirklich aus
am Ende jetzt aber mal wieder konkret
auf auf uns Gemeinden es geht aber auch
darum wir Kommunen müssen kurzfristig
entlastet werden das meine ich doch
genau und da fühlen wir Kommunen alle
miteinander egal ob es die Gemeinden
Städte oder Landkreise sind schon
alleine gelassen davon weil dann gibt es
die Zuständigkeit einmal bund Länder und
da ist aber nicht da wirkliche
Handlungsdruck da weil am Ende werden
die Flüchtlinge die in den staatlichen
Einrichtungen nicht untergebracht werden
die werden den Kommunen zugewiesen und
wir machen es am Ende irgendwie ich habe
dieser Tage interessanten Satz gehört
und nennt sie Faser war es glaube ich
die sagte naja gut dann müssen die
Landräte die zuständige Menschen wie sie
halt mehr Gebäude benutzen freigeben die
im Eigentum des Bundes sind
hat der Bund überall so schöne Gebäude
wie viele haben sie von denen ich habe
in meinem Landkreis davon gar keine
Gebäude an dem Thema sind wir seit
Monaten dran und es geht nicht wirklich
voran also was geht denn durch den Kopf
wenn sie sonst hören da hat sie ja vor
Monaten schon zugesagt 4.000 Immobilien
des Bundes und wenn man sich dann
anschaut was ist das sonst passiert oder
wie viele haben denn von diesen 4000
Immobilien was bekommen das ist sie
haben keine nein ich habe keine nein ich
bin nein von daher ist auch keine Hilfe
zu erwarten und wir erwarten aber sie
kriegen die Leute zugewiesen jede Woche
30 sagen Sie jetzt kommen nächste Woche
wieder 30 wo gehen Sie dann hin wo
klopfen Sie an konkret
es sind mittlerweile verzweifelte Hilfe
Aufrufe bitten an die Bevölkerung wenn
ihr Wohnraum habt bitte meldet euch bei
uns weil ansonsten das nächste ist
unsere Note Untergrund wir haben in
einer alten Schule dank der
Unterstützung der Stadt Klingenberg
haben wir einen altes Schulgebäude vier
Klassenzimmer ein Klassenzimmer ist
jetzt der der Essensraum drei
Klassenzimmer sind Doppelstockbetten für
jeweils 20 Menschen die Note Unterkunft
in der Hoffnung dass die Menschen dort
nur vorübergehend leben wenn wir wieder
Wohnraum haben ich sage auch ganz klar
Turnhallen Sporthallen ist zum einen in
keinster Weise eine vernünftige
Unterbringung ist für mich aber eine
wirkliche rote Linie weil es dann wieder
zu Lasten der Kinder und Jugendlichen
geht der Schulsport der Vereinssport und
das nach zwei oder drei pandemiewintern
und wenn man anschauen was was gerade
die Kinder und Jugendlichen in
vergangenen zwei der drei Jahren
mitgemacht haben an Solidarität zeigen
mussten und und welche Folgen
gesundheitlicher körperliche psychischer
mentale Arzt sie haben kann es kann es
sein dass dass das wieder ist
sie wollten gerade es macht mich
natürlich wahnsinnig als politisch
interessierten Menschen wenn ich höre
wie lange sie schon über dieses Thema
reden dass sie im November Briefe
schreiben das ist ja die anderen mit
beschäftigt sind und dass wir dann in so
einer Phase jetzt irgendwie wieder über
Container Nachdenken über die Frage wo
wir noch eine Kaserne hinkriegen und
dass wir einfach nicht in der Lage sind
dieses Thema mal langfristig anzugehen
und nicht immer nur Pflaster drauf zu
kleben er Flüchtlingspolitik wir haben
gerade
2022 Gerald Knaus der Migrationsforscher
sagt dass er das ja mit der größten
Migrationsbewegungen in Europa seit den
40er Jahren also das
wenn Sie darüber diskutieren ist es
eigentlich noch ist es eigentlich schon
so schlimm also wir hatten letztes Jahr
eine Million Ukraine darauf kam 250.000
Asylanträge jetzt im Januar hatten wir
schon wieder fast 30.000 in Deutschland
soweit ich weiß es ist wirklich ein
riesengroßes Thema aller drei vier Jahre
entdecken wir es mal wieder weil wir
merken jetzt gerade wieder so jetzt
müssen wir irgendwas tun dann reden wir
über containerdörfer und irgendwelche
Sonderschulklassen zum Beispiel oder wir
reden darüber das lecker an die Regie
die Bilder einmal zuspielen sie kennen
die Geschichte aus Opal das ist
mecklenburg-vorpommerndorf kriegen soll
wird gerade wird gerade sozusagen die
Wiese für freigeräumt und im
Gewerbegebiet soweit ich weiß
und das Containerdorf wird halt mehr
Flüchtlinge beherbergen als dieses Dorf
Einwohner hat und wenn man das nicht
ordentlich kommuniziert wenn den Leuten
das nicht einleuchtet dann kriegt man
halt wieder solche Bilder jetzt muss man
sagen den Opal da waren echt finstere
Gestalten unterwegs auch Leute mit denen
man eigentlich nicht zusammen
demonstriert wenn man ein normaler
opaler Bürger ist glaube ich und
trotzdem sowas kommt von sowas ich bin
bin zunehmend ratlos wir müssen
eigentlich seit 2015 in der EU und in
Deutschland daran arbeiten wie wir
dieses Problem wirklich
großflächig ange das heißt wie schaffen
wir es das nicht immer noch der
allergrößte Teil der Leute die über die
Außengrenzen kommen nicht registriert
nicht ordentlich registriert ist wir gar
nicht wissen wer da ins Land kommt wieso
reden wir immer noch nicht ordentlich
darüber
wie wir vielleicht auch Asylverfahren in
Herkunftsländern oder in Drittstaaten
hinkriegen können warum sprechen wir
nicht darüber ja wir sprechen darüber
kriegen es aber nicht hin vielleicht
auch Abkommen mit Ländern zu schließen
die ihre Leute dann zurücknehmen wenn
Sie hier nach einem hoffentlich
schnellen Verfahren das kriegen wir ja
auch nicht hin dann das Land wieder
verlassen müssen er überhaupt liegen wir
seit vielen vielen Jahren dem
Selbstbetrug auf dass dieses Thema
Abschiebung irgendwie was lösen würde
das ist aber nicht so wir sollten
langsam lernen das Abschiebung ganz
schwierig ist dass Leute die einmal da
sind nur sehr sehr selten
Fünftel ungefähr der ausreisepflichtigen
reist überhaupt nur aus oder kann
überhaupt nur abgeschoben werden sehr
sehr selten kriegen wir es hin dieses
Thema über Abschiebung und Ausreise zu
lösen deswegen müssen wir wissen wer ins
Land kommt deswegen brauchen wir
schnelle Verfahren deswegen brauchen wir
vielleicht auch Verfahren an den
Außengrenzen die Außengrenzen wenn ich
nur sagen dafür waren als bayerische
Landräte alle fünf Jahre fahren wir nach
Brüssel wir waren vor fünf Jahren dort
gewesen es wurde uns versprochen 2016
oder 2017 wurde uns frontext die
grenzschutzbehörde versprochen weil es
ja nichts nichts schlimmes dabei ist wir
wollen wissen wer in die Europäische
Union hineinkommt und jetzt waren wir im
November wieder in Brüssel gewesen und
frontext soll jetzt allmählich
einsatzfähig sein aber
erstmal die die die die die sondern die
die harte Frage an Sie als grüner
Landrat
so wird Zäune aufstellen
an bestimmten Grenzen zum Beispiel wo
Bulgarien Türkei sind sie dafür Zäune
aufzustellen ich ich bin ganz klar dafür
dass dass wir Kontrolle darüber haben
wer in die Europäische Union hineinkommt
sie erinnern sich ja meine Frage sind
sie dafür Zäune aufzustellen ich weiß
nicht am Ende ob ob Zäune wirklich bei
der Größe ob das das ist was zu werden
damit habe ich am Ende auch keine
Probleme wenn es das wirkungsvolle
Mittel wäre ja weil wir müssen doch es
ist doch es ist doch nichts ethisch
verwerfliches daran dass wir eine
Kontrolle darüber haben wollen dass wir
wissen wollen wer in die europäische
hin-union hineinkommt und es ist doch
nur ehrlich aber Spitzen Leute dass ihre
Partei ganz ganz anders darüber aber die
müssen sich damit auseinandersetzen dass
wir in der Europäischen Union erstmal
wir als Bürgerinnen und Bürger einen
enormen Wohlstand dadurch haben dass wir
uns frei bewegen können wir haben
innerhalb der Europäischen Union die
Freizügigkeit und die Waren können sich
frei bewegen und am Ende des Tages
irgendwann muss ich doch sowieso wissen
wer Europäische Union wer ins Land
gekommen ist und das möchte ich am Ende
Europäische Union an der Grenze schon
wissen
eigentlich kein Problem eigentlich für
ein staatliches Gebilde eine
Selbstverständlichkeit
dadurch werden es noch nicht weniger
aber es geht einfach darum dass die
Menschen direkt registriert sind dass
ich weiß wer es ist und dann stellt sich
die Frage lassen sie rein wen lassen sie
nicht rein wie machen sie das ja aber
anhand der Verfahren sie durchlaufen ja
nur die Frage ist ja wann durchlaufen
Sie das Verfahren und ist das ein
Verfahren durch unser BAM durch das
Bundesamt für Migration und und und
Flüchtlinge ist das ein Verfahren was
über ein Jahr dauern muss oder geht das
nicht zügiger und am Ende wäre konkret
der steht jetzt da an dieser an diesem
Zaun den wir jetzt da bauen und sagte
Asyl ja lassen Sie ihn erst mal rein
dann kommt der Macher weg und sagt wenn
er erstmal drin ist bleibt er hier ja
das ist gelebte Wirklichkeit auch wenn
hier regelmäßig Menschen aus der SPD
vorzugsweise anderes behaupten aber dann
bleibt er hier also ich glaube das ist
realistischen umsetzbare Möglichkeit
wäre weil das natürlich nicht während
ich am Grenzzaun stehe und mit dem
Söllner spreche
und der entscheidet dann ja dann brauche
ich aber dort
Aufenthaltszonen wo die Menschen dann
auch für für mehrere Tage oder Wochen
bleiben können das ist ja nichts anderes
als was wir momentan mit staatlichen
Einrichtungen innerhalb Deutschlands
haben das muss ja am Ende nicht ein
einen meinen augenindiskutables
Verfahren sein dass ein Jawort sondern
würden sich das Verfahren beschleunigen
die Leute im Zweifel wieder
zurückschicken das zum einen entweder
direkt an der EU-Außengrenze oder
natürlich auch wenn wir mal eine
vernünftige belastbare Flüchtlingshilfe
haben vor Ort natürlich auch dann schon
in Krisenregionen
die Möglichkeit besteht ja also ich weiß
ja nicht aus sowohl an der EU
Außengrenze
Aufenthaltsräume in denen das Verfahren
ablaufen kann als auch das wird es
wirklich auch verlagern wenn wir vor Ort
in den Regionen in den großen
flüchtlingszentren die wirklich
menschenwürdige Bedingungen liefern das
auch dort die Menschen die Möglichkeit
haben eine Antrag auf Asyl oder eine
ganz wichtig dann muss ich auch nicht
mehr der Bevölkerung erklären warum denn
gefühlt zu 90 oder 95% nur noch Männer
zwischen 15 und 25 diesen brutalen von
Kriminalität geprägten Weg zurücklegen
sondern wir können auch wieder kommen
wieder dahin dass wir Familien Kindern
Frauen und alten Menschen helfen gut